[Música]
la Organización Mundial de la Salud
anunció que revisará su evaluación es de
riesgo gluco global respecto de la gripe
aviar h5n1 lados pequeños brotes en
varios países el último en Argentina que
decidió suspender las exportaciones de
productos avícolas además dos personas
de una misma familia también se
contagiaron en Camboya una niña de 11
años que falleció y su padre que no tuvo
síntomas los casos informados en la
semana pasada generaron preocupaciones
por una nueva variante que surgió en el
año 2020 y que ha causado un número
récord de muertes entre aves silvestres
y domésticas en los últimos ves en meses
vamos al análisis de este tema con
Margarita de vale ella es investigadora
científica viróloga e inmunóloga
coordinadora de la plataforma
interdisciplinaria de investigación en
salud global del csc bienvenida a
Margarita Gracias por estar en directo
América y nos acompaña también nuestra
periodista de salud Omar Romero Buenos
días Margarita Buenos días encantada de
estar con ustedes desde Madrid Pues bien
Si le parece vamos a comenzar los casos
de esta variante que fue identificada en
el 2020 han sido esporádicos y no se ha
comprobado aún el contagio de humano a
humano pero le quiero preguntar si hay
preocupaciones adicionales por estos
casos de Camboya en el que en los que
los enfermos eran dos personas de una
misma familia
bueno la nueva variante es la que está
circulando entre las aves y
efectivamente causando una mortalidad
que hacía tiempo que no causaba sin
embargo la que ha pasado por ejemplo a
estos casos esporádicos que está
ocurriendo en particular en Camboya es
una variante que llevaba ya mucho tiempo
circulando en Camboya O sea no es una
nueva variante es una variante que nunca
se había detectado en años anteriores
que se transmitiese entre personas
sí quería preguntarle no parece
precisamente ya pasando de lo de Camboya
no estás nueva variante que decía está
más adaptada a aves sobre todo aves
salvajes migratorias y también a
mamíferos no ha causado brotes entre
animales mamíferos aquí en Latinoamérica
Por ejemplo si eso podría implicar como
decían algunos expertos que estamos en
una panzoote es decir en una especie de
pandemia de los animales
bueno está claro que con la pandemia de
coronavirus hemos aprendido a
intensificar la vigilancia que había
antes de gripe aviar y ahora está mucho
más intensificada y en particular en
Sudamérica y también se está vigilando
más en mamíferos entonces con ello se
está teniendo una información mucho más
potente la que se tenía antes Y además
están tomando reacciones más tempranas
porque es otro de las enseñanzas de la
pandemia de coronavirus Cuanto más
pronto se corten las cadenas de contagio
en animales o en personas es mejor lo
que sí que es cierto es que sin embargo
llevamos venimos de una de unos años en
los cuales no ha habido estas epidemias
en no ha habido tantas epidemias en las
aves en particular no ha habido tantas
tantos casos de
personas que se contagiesen a partir de
la gripe aviar no se transmitía
prácticamente el virus entre personas
pero es que además había muy pocos
contagios en personas durante 12 años de
2004 a 2015 hubo un cierto número
razonablemente estable de contagios a
personas y de personas que fallecían
fallecían aproximadamente la mitad de
las que se contagiaban es una enfermedad
muy grave cuando pasa a las personas y
se contagiaban alrededor de 70 personas
cada año luego hubo unos años de
tranquilidad en que esto no ocurría en
las personas Pero ha vuelto ahora
empezar a ocurrir menos casos que los
que había antes todavía Entonces estamos
más vigilantes que antes por eso estamos
en las noticias pero todavía el riesgo
sigue siendo limitado hay que estar muy
observante eso sin ninguna duda esa
enseñanza no la podemos olvidar pero el
riesgo sigue siendo limitado a nivel de
panzotía que es lo que me estaba
preguntando pregunten más a los
especialistas en veterinaria
efectivamente parece que hay muchos pero
son ellos los que sabrán más Cuánto está
aumentando está claro que se está
detectando mucho más bueno teniendo en
cuenta todo lo que usted nos dice y este
llamado a estar vigilantes le quería
preguntar cómo sucede el contagio de la
gripe aviar para que nuestros
televidentes estén atentos y cómo se
reduce la exposición a la enfermedad
bueno los contagios que se han detectado
Durante los últimos 20 años suelen ser
siempre con personas que están muy cerca
del trabajo o la manipulación doméstica
con aves que están enfermas Entonces eso
es lo que hay que evitar sobre todo
cuando las aves están enfermas evitarlo
pero cuando no están enfermas Pues
también en cuanto hay un caso pues
mantener mucho más la separación el
contagio se podría evitar quizás con
mascarillas no lo sabemos Exactamente no
sabemos si eso hace falta
introducirlo en toda la manipulación de
aves pero cuando haya casos desde luego
notificarlos inmediatamente para pararlo
todavía no se sabe que podría ocurrir
para que tuviese lugar el contagio entre
personas es decir qué factores tener en
cuenta porque en el caso de estos estos
dos familiares en Camboya el padre ha
resultado sin síntomas la niña Ha
fallecido ambos pudieron estar expuestos
a la vez o con poca diferencia a la
Fuente las aves enfermas en relación al
distinto quizás porque se han inoculado
Con distinta cantidad de virus quizás
porque tenían distinta constitución en
ese momento distinta fortaleza pero
todavía no sabemos cómo evitarlo lo que
está claro es que todavía no se puede
decir que haya transmisión entre
personas que sería un salto fundamental
en el nivel de alerta para las personas
Porque estos casos agrupados familiares
posibles posición a la vez
al virus de las aves han ocurrido en el
pasado en aquellos 12 años en que había
unos 70 casos de gripe aviar en humanos
ocurrían de vez en cuando O sea no era
inusual que esto ocurriese sí yo quería
preguntarle sabemos que este virus
todavía le cuesta no saltar a humanos
como estaba diciendo pero hemos visto
que se está acercando pues por ejemplo
la capacidad de infectar a mamíferos yo
quería preguntar sabiendo que los virus
evolucionan que mutan que se van
adaptando si Precisamente es una
cuestión de tiempo que un virus así
pueda llegar a infectarnos a nosotros
es una cuestión de tiempo claramente y
por eso estamos vigilantes por eso desde
hace ya bastantes años está sobre todo
esta vigilancia de la gripe por lo
mortal que es y porque Puede ocurrir en
cualquier momento puede tardar mucho
puede tardar poco la vigilancia es lo
que nos va a permitir estar alertas y
además otra cosa muy importante la gripe
como muchas de las enfermedades
respiratorias se transmiten mayor o
menor cantidad por aerosoles entonces
estar también alertas en cuanto a saber
que cuando algo se transmite a partir
del tracto respiratorio superior porque
emitimos el virus porque exhalamos
porque tosemos por las secreciones pues
hay que tener en cuenta esta distancia
esta higiene y también el control del
aire la calidad del aire Es decir que el
aire en grandes espacios interiores que
está un poco ventilados tenga mejor
calidad y es una de las de los retos del
futuro no hacia lo que tenemos que ir
Vamos a aprender de las pandemias de
agentes que se transmiten por vías
respiratorias para poder evitar que algo
que puede ser una epidemia local que en
cualquier lugar del mundo que evitemos
que eso llegue a expandirse por todo el
continente o expandirse por todo el
mundo y a ser otra vez una pandemia eso
tiene ser una de las enseñanzas que nos
quede muy claramente y por ahora Este sí
por esto estamos con la vigilancia pero
lo que está muy claro es que por ahora
este virus el virus aviar está
infectando los pulmones muy
profundamente y por eso causa Esa esa
enfermedad tan grave pero todavía no se
multiplica con con facilidad en la parte
superior del tracto respiratorio y por
eso no se contagia fácilmente entre
personas bueno Margarita por eso estamos
como le decía poniendo el tema sobre la
mesa y ante esta actitud de vigilancia
esa Margarita de baal investigadora
científica viróloga e inmunóloga
invitada de France 24 gracias a usted
encantada muchísimas gracias y el
acompañamiento de ustedes mal por la
asesoría también vamos a hacer una
pequeña pausa y ya volvemos con más de
directo a América
[Música]